I'm feeling very dark from back to the
future today hello my name is grace
Helbig if you did not know welcome to my
youtube channel I'm really proud of you
for being here going to have a really
fun time together
this isn't facetious this is my genuine
authentic emotional outpouring of love
and pride for you now you probably can
tell by the title of this video what
this video is about it is how I edit my
Instagram photos I have to say this is
one of my most highly requested video
requests ever you guys asked me about
this all the time if you go to my
Instagram you probably you get why this
is so highly requested it's kind of
bizarre people write in the comments
email song parodies requesting this
video sometimes I walk by strangers on
the street and they don't say anything
out loud but I can see in their eyes
that they really want for me to make
this video unborn babies send a lot of
like
sonar signals to me requesting this
video I had a really spiritual
experience over the weekend in which
Jesus Christ actually asked me about how
I edit my Instagram photos
lots of prison inmates send me mail
asking for this video dream the girl
band started by P Diddy actually had a
reunion concert recently and in the
concert they requested that I make this
video my accountant mentioned it so you
know just a lot so I thought finally I
will make this video for you here is how
I edit my Instagram photos the first
thing you do to edit an Instagram photo
is oh my god shut up dog it's taken
Instagram photos so I just do some
general lady
shut up goose some general lady prep and
then I try and find a natural oh my god
goose a natural light source so that I
can really work the angles goose my god
work those angles from there I edit my
photos in an app called disco camp
because one time my teenager told me if
I wasn't using disco Kim I was an idiot
and it truly made me feel insecure your
words have weight people
so now I use vsco cam but vsco cam has
so many options for retouching or me
coloring your photos that it makes me
extra insecure because I don't know what
colours look cool and what colors make
my life more interesting than I am
I am on a human level like Connor Franta
and jennxpenn use a lot of like blue
tones and that looks really cool like
their indie artists even though they're
not musicians and i feel like i should
be doing something like that but then I
think that's trying too hard and so
usually these thoughts spiral into some
sort of quarter life crisis in which I
end up standing in my backyard and
wondering what actually is color then I
usually sit in this chair that I never
sit in my backyard so I can just
validate the purchase that I like to go
inside and have a deep and rich
conversation with my dog about color
because she's colorblind and then
sometimes I walk around and I wonder
about the things that actually don't
have the opportunity to have Instagram
in the first place and I think about how
lucky I am and how grateful I am for the
opportunities that have these extra
insecurities that a lot of other things
don't have and then I quickly give him a
neighbor's the middle finger and then I
walk by these prints I have in my home
that I got from the internet and I think
wow these are such great photos so don't
I just take photos of these photos and
use them with my own photos and post
them to the internet but I think that's
the stupid no one does it on the
internet no one takes any photos or
phrases that they don't actually own and
then use it and then I have business
meetings and then I gain some
inspiration by sitting back and watching
some of my favorite YouTube videos while
enjoying a hearty and helpful breakfast
and then I do some daily affirmations at
this point of usually bursting over with
inspiration and I'm able to choose the
perfect filter for that photo we took
earlier from there I upload it to my
Instagram feeling cool confident and
others well there you go I hope that
this gave you some helpful tips on
editing your Instagram photos and a
little more insight into my creative
process you can see why I don't post as
often as I should on Instagram it takes
a long time to edit a good photo but
talking about Instagram photos is a
really great segue for me to mention
this hey look I love Instagram and as
much as I make fun of people that post
their food photos on Instagram I
secretly want to be able to post my food
photo as an Instagram but I know that
there will be judgment because people
like me exist in the world and working
on my judgment you guys I'm working on
it I swear fear no more those of you
that might have also been afraid to post
food photos on Instagram dish
this is a food photo app that has been
copilot wire myself Hannah Hart mamrie
Hart and Ingrid Nelson and we were so
excited to be finally launching this
thing you might have seen us posting on
it in the last few weeks it's so much
fun dy SH you can download it an app
store it's available for Android and
iPhone please go check it out you can
post photos of your food you can rate it
you can critique it you can follow
others that post photos of their food
it's basically a non-judgmental food
community for the amateur and
professional foodie alike I am NOT a
foodie and that world intimidates me so
much which is why I am so excited to be
presenting the dish community to you a
community of food lovers that will not
intimidate you at all just check out my
profile pretty much like someone let a
third-grader rate food I really like
this a lot and I'm really proud of
myself and Hannah and mamrie and Ingrid
for co-founding this and making it
happen and now it's here for you and for
us so I hope that you guys go check it
out if you want to and follow me on dish
cuz I'm I'm they're posting all sorts of
weird and wonderful things that's it
I don't know did you like this video I
went too far I know I did I'm sorry
nothing no god bless you
I forgot you're an atheist